zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un Europe sur
Radio sensation et en association avec
TV 78 une émission réalisée au Parlement
européen de Strasbourg un flashback pour
commencer David sasoli à occuper la
présidente du Parlement européen de 2019
à 2022 on revient sur son parcours avec
Alberto bevillaca chargé de mission pour
Europe Direct Seine-et-Marne
zone Europe sur sensation
cette année l'Union européenne et ses
institutions ont été marquées par la
disparition d'une figure qui restera à
jamais gravée dans l'histoire David
sassol président du Parlement européen
emporté par une maladie incurable
quelques semaines avant la fin de son
mandat
David ça se lit né un Florence en 1956
avant de s'engager en politique fut tout
d'abord un journaliste bien connu et
reconnu par les Italiens il a été en
effet directeur et visage du Djoule JT
de 20 heures de rayons chaîne historique
de l'audiovisuel public italien les
Italiens le connaissent avant tout comme
journaliste dans les premières années
2000 alors qu'il avait déjà fait montre
de son activisme lorsqu'il était rentré
très jeune dans le mouvement catholique
des scouts italiens
tout au long de son parcours il promeut
ainsi les valeurs qui lui ont été
transmises afin d'apporter quelque chose
de meilleur à la société Willy pour
cette raison en 2009 il décide de mettre
en pause sa carrière de journaliste pour
entreprendre une nouvelle aventure
politique qui démarre avec succès il
devient ainsi député européen avec 400
000 voix l'un des meilleurs scores
jamais atteints dans l'histoire d'un
candidat italien aux élections
européennes malgré l'échec de sa
candidature à la mairie de Rome il était
le vice-président du Parlement européen
sa carrière attend le sommet lors de son
élection en tant que président du
Parlement européen l'exercice de son
mandat est caractérisée par la volonté
de s'inspirer des pères fondateurs de
l'Union européenne son œuvre en tant que
grande défenseur de l'Union est
remarquable surtout lors des crises
majeures comme celle liée à la pandémie
en effet il prônera sans cesse une
coopération étroite des États membres
voire une construction fédéraliste
inspirée par celle dessinée dans le
manifeste de vente hôtel écrit par halte
Pinel
il se tient avec hardeur le programme
next generation new pour redresser
l'économie européenne post covid et
lutte acharnement pour réformer le
budget européen de l'objectif de lui
donner un caractère fédéral il ouvre
aussi pour rapprocher les citoyens des
institutions européennes grâce à la
promotion de la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'Europe grandeultation citoyenne qui
permet aux Européens de s'exprimer pour
redessiner l'Europe selon leur propre
vision pour honorer sa mémoire nous lui
devons de continuer son œuvre en
s'inspirant de lui pour apporter quelque
chose de meilleur dont la société et
surtout dans l'Europe nous vivons un
autre tour donc et on le dira jamais
assez grâce et 1000 David
zone Europe l'invité politique
bonjour Mathias grouden bonjour vous
êtes diplomate slovène directeur de la
participation démocratique au sein du
Conseil de l'Europe c'est une
institution
intergouvernementale composée de 46
États membres et dont le siège se situe
à Strasbourg dans ce qu'on appelle le
Palais de l'Europe le Conseil de
l'Europe c'est une vieille institution
c'est fondée en 1949 par plusieurs États
dont la France alors attention ça ne
doit pas être confondu avec l'Union
européenne qui elle compte 27 États
membres mais donc à quoi est-ce qu'il
sert ce Conseil de l'Europe Machiavel
oui merci avant que j'ai répondu une
petite correction
j'étais diplomate Slovénie il y a très
longtemps mais depuis que je suis au
Conseil de l'Europe en effet je suis un
fonctionnaire européen Jean du Conseil
de l'Europe c'est à dire que je
travaille autant pour la France que pour
la Slovénie en effet c'est la loi
à cette organisation à ces valeurs c'est
une des conditions de notre de notre
travail mais juste pour
classifier ce qui ce qui me paraît quand
même important le Conseil de l'Europe le
Conseil de l'Europe
et
une réponse ou la réponse
de l'Europe à son propre passé on lit
très souvent que le projet européen
est-ce qu'on dit projet européen je
parle du Conseil de l'Europe de l'Union
européenne parce qu'ils sont issus d'une
même vision on dit souvent que c'était
une réponse à la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ce qui est vrai réfléchit pas et
on comprend pas vraiment de
quelle façon ces liens cette réponse
était pas uniquement éthique morale mais
elle était politique elle était
juridique qu'elle était liée à ce qui
s'est passé par uniquement pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais surtout ce
qui s'est passé pendant les années 30
le Conseil de l'Europe est une
organisation qui était créée pour
assurer que la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme est respectée dans ces
pays membres tout ce que nous faisons à
travers nos différents institutions
le secrétaire général l'Assemblée
parlementaire la congrès du pouvoir
locaux
le but de nos activités c'est
effectivement de créer des circonstances
de favoriser des promouvoir le respect
des droits qui sont protégés par la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et de effectivement créer les
circonstances ou d'aider la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui qui
fait partie de notre système du Conseil
de l'Europe à faire son travail
justement il y a un Comité des Ministres
qui est composé des ministres des
Affaires étrangères de chaque État
membre et puis il y a aussi c'est assez
peu connu une assemblée parlementaire
qui se réunit quatre fois par an avec
des parlementaires donc de tous les
États membres tous les États qui
intègrent le Conseil de l'Europe vous
l'avez dit doivent signer aussi la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qu'est-ce qu'elle contient cette
convention
la Convention
très souvent moi on me demande
d'expliquer aux jeunes la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme ce qui
est très important parce que très
souvent les jeunes ils ont une
sentiment une conviction que les droits
de l'homme les libertés fondamentales
sont quelque chose de très abstrait
quelque chose qui ne les concerne pas
quelque chose qui est uniquement
pertinent pour les autres mais pas
quelque chose qui joue un rôle important
dans leur vie
je vais retourner à à cette réponse où
j'ai évoqué
les années 30
je dirais que la Convention européenne
elle est un résultat de
ce que en bon onglet on dirait River
c'est une générique où les juristes
après la deuxième guerre ils ont étudié
chaque étape dans cette descente à
l'unité qu'on a vu dans l'Europe des
années 30 et ils ont créé une sauvegarde
une réponse
qui devrait nous protéger que ce genre
de que ce genre de crime se répète que
ce genre de crimes commis par les
Européens contre les Européens ne se
répètent plus et on voit ça très
facilement c'est parce que si on voit
des différents articles de la Convention
qui a garanti la droit à la vie
familiale on peut penser des la
législation des lois de Nuremberg
des années 30 quand on parle liberté de
l'association Liberté de l'expression
par le droit
un procès équitable protection contre la
esclavage contre les traitements
inhumains et la fin des Droits de la Vie
tout ça suit cette comme j'ai dit
descente qui a commencé au début des
années à 30 et qui finalement avec une
vie à la session les plus brutale le
plus humain de la droite à la vie c'est
terminé dans les dans les dans les
chambres des gaz des des concentrations
et donc pour pouvoir l'appliquer cette
convention Conseil de l'Europe dispose
de la Cour européenne droit de l'homme
elle peut condamner directement les
États pour faute en quoi cette cour de
justice selon vous permet d'améliorer la
démocratie au sein de l'Europe
je crois que d'un côté
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
est essentiel il est aussi unique on ne
connaît pas un autre mécanisme
international qui permettrait
des personnes individuelles aux citoyens
individuels de porter plainte contre un
gouvernement pour la violation des de
leurs droits déjà ça c'est unique on a
d'autres tribunaux internationaux ou un
gouvernement peut porter plainte contre
un autre gouvernement on a des Tribunal
international pour les crimes de guerre
ou la communauté internationale peut
effectivement faire les procès contre
les in individuels qui ont commis ou qui
sont accusés du comité mais les tribunal
ou un citoyen
après qu'il a fait tout ce qu'il faut
faire au niveau national qu'il peut
porter effectivement
faire un procès contre son gouvernement
pour la violation de ses doigts ça c'est
unique c'est très important mais il faut
aussi dire une autre chose que
les droits de l'homme pour avoir une
protection efficace pour qu'on peut
avoir une société où les droits de
l'homme et les libertés fondamentales
sont effectivement à pleinement
respectés on peut pas s'en
occuper uniquement de Strasbourg et des
bâtiments qu'on va se les
droit humain les libertés fondamentales
le respect de la dignité humaine de tous
doivent effectivement être la réalité
qui est garantie et assurée
au niveau national où sont où il y a les
plupart des responsabilités
il faut qu'il y a une volonté politique
réelle de la part des forces politiques
de la population qui doit accepter
les valeurs d'une société démocratique
et être prêt à son engager au niveau
local
et uniquement quand il y a des
difficultés qui arrivent souvent
le mécanisme de la coopaine de
doualables intervient comme comme
le dernier secours si vous voyez mais on
peut pas compter que tout va être réglé
de Strasbourg les droits de l'homme
ce respect ou pas de nos pays vous
mangez vous êtes directeur de la
participation démocratique au sein du
Conseil de l'Europe j'imagine que vous
êtes particulièrement vigilant aux
atteintes démocratiques qui pourraient
survenir en Europe en quoi consiste
votre travail au quotidien
je vais reprendre avec une très belle
histoire il y a quelques années j'étais
invité au Parlement européen
à Bruxelles sur une conférence qui a
traité la question qu'est-ce qu'il faut
avoir dans une société pour avoir une
vraie démocratie qu'est-ce qu'il faut
pour avoir une vraie démocratie c'était
organisé par les
groupes politiques du Parlement et
l'Association internationale des avocats
alors il avait plein de juristes et des
personnalités politiques ils ont tous
parlé des institutions il faut une
Constitution il faut un Parlement il
faut des lois il fait un équilibre de
pouvoir
si c'est une judiciaire et
ils avaient raison c'est tout à fait on
peut pas avoir une démocratie sans ces
institution mais ce que j'ai appris à
ajouter avant la conférence c'est
terminé c'est que pour avoir une vraie
démocratie on a aussi besoin d'un
environnement démocratique parce que les
institutions ne perdent pas ne
fonctionnent pas dans le vide pour avoir
une vraie démocratie il faut qu'on a un
environnement où les citoyens ont les
opportunités possibilités motivation
des connaissances
qui sont nécessaires pour être un
citoyen actif et
deuxièmement il faut avoir un respect
pour les valeurs
humaines dans la société et
troisièmement ce que je disais toujours
il faut avoir la mémoire historique pour
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
une société quand les droits humaines ne
sont pas respectés et continuent pas
démocratie voilà c'est ça et ce que nous
faisons dans la direction de la
participation démocratique en organise
la coopération entre tous nos 46 pays
membres dont le domaine où cet
environnement
démocratique et construit protéger et
épanouie ça veut dire ce sont les
domaines de l'éducation ce que
l'éducation pour la citoyenneté
démocratique jeunesse
culture et patrimoine voilà les champs
principales de mes responsabilités 46
pays membres et pas 47 la Russie a été
exclue du Conseil de l'Europe après
l'invasion de l'Ukraine en février 2022
selon l'euro baromètre de l'été 2022 58%
des citoyens de l'Union européenne sont
favorables aux sanctions envers la
Russie pour donc la sanctionner de cette
invasion alors comment est-ce que vous
vous analysez ce résultat est-ce que ça
vous confirme que l'Europe est une le
terre de démocratie selon vous qui
défend les valeurs démocratiques bon je
crois que je crois que la réponse doit
être un peu plus nuancée
vous avez dit 56 58 50 88 je crois que
c'est
encourageant c'est un soulagement qu'il
y a 58% des citoyens européens même que
peut-être la distribution dans dans les
différents pays peut être peuvent varier
qu'il y a une majorité assez claire
conviction qu'on peut pas uniquement
laisser faire et juste regarder une
telle
violation
des de la souveraineté d'un pays
européen un des crimes qui sont commis
et de la violation des des droits
internationales de cet envergure ceci
dit il faut après aussi dire qu'il a 42%
des Européens qui ne partagent pas cette
opinion je crois pas c'est quelque chose
que qu'on peut simplement
ignorer
je crois que
il faut réfléchir il faut vraiment
essayer de comprendre pourquoi on est
arrivé là pourquoi un peu moins de 50%
des des des gens en tel opinion trouver
les raisons et et répondre à à ces
questions on peut le comprendre de façon
psychologique on était tous j'étais
d'une tranquillité peut-être naïve dans
une situation de guerre les gens une
réaction ils veulent que
on peut que
que les montres
se tourne à l'arrière que le temps se
tourna l'arrière qu'on puisse vivre
comme on a vécu avant cette
traumatisme qui est intervenu par les 24
février je crois qu'il s'est un
processus qui a commencé beaucoup plus
tôt
il faut comprendre pourquoi il y en a
tellement de nos citoyens qui sont
tellement prêts à chercher les
informations à accepter les
désinformations pourquoi elle préfère
des des informations qui correspond à
leur besoin émotionnels au lieu de
essayer de regarder et comprendre et
répondre au fait de ces traumatisme
qu'on est en train de vivre en Europe
vous parlez donc de désinformations avec
cette guerre on a revu l'importance des
des médias que qui peuvent avoir sur
l'opinion publique notamment la
désinformation aussi à affaibli les
démocraties
oui mais je crois que le deuxième
formation est plutôt un symptôme
qui
il y a faut comprendre d'un côté il y a
il y a une côté à
des conditions se plaignent en anglais
il y a toujours comme dans l'économie il
est la demande il y a le l'offre l'offre
il a une offre de désinformation qui est
de plus en plus intense qui qui qui est
mis au marché si je peux le dire pour
des raisons évidentes mais il faut aussi
comprendre qu'il y a une démonte pour
l'information et c'est là où on doit se
demander pourquoi il y a un tel demande
pour la désinformation sur les
différents sujets guerre en Ukraine
pandémie
et là je crois que ça reflète une
profonde manque de confiance
des nos citoyens dont leur institutions
politiques de l'institution de la
démocratie
et c'est ça le vrai problème c'est que
on a perdu notre
capacité de se défendre collectivement
contre contre la deuxième formation
parce qu'il y en a parce qu'on a perdu
cette confiance
sont lesquelles une démocratie peut pas
fonctionner on peut pas avoir une
démocratie si moquiez ou presque moitié
des citoyens ne croient pas à
aux institutions de ce système mais on
peut pas juste imposer ou décréter une
telle confiance il faut la gagner il
faut effectivement
tout la responsabilité je dirais de
notre classe politique mais de tous les
autres acteurs de la société
de
d'abord d'accepter une telle réalité là
de comprendre la gravité de la situation
d'identifier les voix pour regagner
cette confiance et finalement de le
faire mais je suis pas sûr qu'on a dans
la bonne route toujours pour finir
Mathias grüden un dernier mot sur une
des conséquences donc de ce confit c'est
l'inflation partout en Europe selon
toujours l'euro baromètre de l'été 2022
la principale préoccupation des
Européens c'est ça c'est l'inflation
c'est les conséquences économiques de
cette crise est-ce que des troubles
sociaux pourraient survenir et
fragiliser les démocraties est-ce que
c'est ce que ça vous inquiète bien sûr
qu'elles vont le faire c'est qu'on a
déjà vu que l'ont déjà fait
une des raisons de de cette perte de
confiance c'est aussi la crise
financière et la façon dont on a traité
ces conséquences je crois que qui ont
aussi créé
des des qui ont eu des des conséquences
économiques et des conséquences sociales
et qui ont contribué à cette création de
grands réservoirs des citoyens frustrés
fâchés
mécontents avec un sentiment d'injustice
très souvent justifié
qui ont perdu leur confiance qui ont qui
se sont sentis abandonnés qui sont
sortis que les institutions de
démocratie et la démocratie comme
système ne fonctionne pas pour eux
qu'ils les a oublié et qu'ils ont
commencé à chercher
d'alternative et je crois que là quand
on parle d'inflation l'inflation je suis
pas économiste mais l'inflation est une
des dimensions d'une profonde crise
économique elle serait elle reflète
aussi dans la dans l'inflation qui aura
des conséquences au niveau économique
qui a des conséquences numéro
économiques qui aura des conséquences
sociales et ça sans une réaction
économique politique sociale va
davantage
mettant danger à notre système
démocratique bien sûr merci beaucoup
Mathias griden d'avoir été avec nous
dans un Europe je rappelle donc que vous
êtes directeur de la participation
démocratique au Conseil de l'Europe
zone Europe l'invité politique
[Musique]
le cinéma européen à l'honneur à présent
avec Sami blood lauréat du Prix luxe en
2017 ce film réalisé par Amanda Carnel
raconte l'histoire de Samy 14 ans en
Laponie c'est la chronique de Louis
break étudiant à l'ICP el Marja est une
fille issue du peuple Sami cette tribu
peut autochtone qui vit dans le nord de
la Suède est exclu par le reste de la
population la jeune fille va alors tout
faire pour s'intégrer dans la société
[Musique]
entre le harcèlement de ses camarades et
le conflit familial l'aîné Cécilia
sparrock et pousse parfaitement le rôle
de pionnière dans cette quête à
l'éducation
ça a été une grosse surprise
nous avons eu beaucoup de retours de la
part de personnes indigènes qui ont été
traitées de cette manière pendant pas
mal de temps dans les années 40
le peuple Sami a été maltraité mis dans
différentes écoles les écoles nomades
qui étaient largement différenciées des
écoles suédoises
ici nous avons un message universel
qui incarne le personnage principal
elle Maria dans le film andos la cause
du droit à l'éducation
devant la justice
ça devrait être une cause universelle ce
film a aussi remporté le prix du godborg
Film Festival d'une valeur d'un million
de couronnes suédoises soit environ
115000 euros c'est une des plus grandes
récompenses du monde
zone Europe sur sensation
zone Europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du Parlement européen de Strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
notre application radio sensation et
aussi sur TV 78 nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]